before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
previously on council of geeks
davies stop messing with me
and now on council of geeks
russell
whatever it is that i did
that made you want to work me to death
i'm sorry
i am
so sorry
[Music]
so the doctor who
news
just
keeps
coming
ah and hopefully i won't have a repeat
of what happened with the last video
which was that
literally almost to the freaking
minute that i released it it was out of
date because more stuff came out i'm
hoping to have this up before that
happens to me again
but it might and if this keeps drip
feeding out at the pace that it's been
at some point i'm going to have to stop
i'm too stubborn to do it yet but
just
be aware
i am trying to get other things done
this week
besides quick turnaround doctor who
videos but
my supposition in the last video
that the reason for announcing the
return of david tennant and katherine
tate to the show um happening when it
did probably was to get ahead of them
actually starting shooting and being
photographed on set was completely
validated by the fact that we have now
started getting
photographs showing up
of these actors in particular
outa tardis
and in
some
slightly modified costumes i'll get to
some of this if you're here for
speculation i'm gonna do a little not a
ton
mainly because i'm seeing a lot of
speculation already running rampant to
the fact that i'm seeing people spawning
theories that are spin-offs of other
people's theories which are based off
information that they're treating as
fact which is not confirmed so i'm not
going very far down that rabbit hole but
i will absolutely talk about what we
know and some of the base level
possibilities of what it may or may not
mean
david tennant catherine tate already
announced we now have photographs of
them on set it's interesting that tenant
while in a very tenth doctor-esque
outfit it's not a perfect match for any
of his previous costumes which would
seem to indicate that this is less
likely to be a missing story something
that happened
with the doctor and donna during their
time together that we just hadn't seen
before there's also another indication
that makes that unlikely which is that
we have
confirmed spotted on set
wilf
bernard cribbens is back now this
actually
makes a heck of a lot of sense because
if you're bringing donna back wilf is
very tied to him and they both shared
the same last episode appearing in the
show
now wilf being there makes it even
less likely that this was a story that
sort of took place
during the original time in which we
know the doctor and donald were
traveling because we have a much cleaner
um idea of when wilf was traveling
uh with the doctor and it was very
limited in scope and also given the fact
that we see willf
i'm making use of a wheelchair uh it's
not i couldn't really find anyone saying
for certain whether that was simply a
mobility aid to cribbins himself or if
that was actually
like something that was uh you know just
to get him from um from set to set or
what have you or if they are actually
having wilf as a character be in a
wheelchair i don't know
um
but if as a character
wilf is in a wheelchair that would be
another thing to indicate more time
having passed from last time we saw them
since wilf was not making use of a
wheelchair when we saw him previously so
this seems to have
i'm not going to say one with 100
certainty but
pretty firmly eliminated one of the
previous possibilities of exactly how
the doctor and donna and now wilf are
being integrated into this new story
still presumably the 60th anniversary
special
so that's
the first thing i'll touch on briefly
some people have speculated that the
doctor's altered outfit might make this
the meta crisis doctor
which that's possible though the
metacrisis doctor in terms of where he
was left off was most tied to rose tyler
uh we'll come back to news regarding a
character named rose hold on i've got a
lot to get through here um it is true
that the meta crisis doctor also came
out of the situation that resulted in
the doctor donna and what happened with
donna noble so it's not completely out
of the realm of possibility that this
could be the metacrisis doctor although
if it is the metacrisis doctor the
glaring question is if he's here where's
rose or at least wears billy piper as
rose which brings us to
the second thing to talk about which is
that yasmine finney who is an actress
i'm not familiar with she's apparently
on hot heart stoppers which is another
show that people have told me i should
watch but again like it's a it's a high
school friggin thing i don't enjoy
watching high school movies or shows
i'm sure they're good i'm sure they're
good but i just
i'm not in a headspace where i can
relate to that kind of
everything is the most dramatic thing in
your life ever mentality i remember
being in reality i don't find it
entertaining to dip back into that space
so no i haven't seen heart stoppers i
don't currently plan to see heart
stoppers however yasmin finney is best
known for that series at present and she
is confirmed to be playing a character
named rose now it's very important that
you understand that at the very least at
the time of my speaking
she is only confirmed to be playing a
character named rose that
is
it i've seen numerous
supposed news outlets falsely report
that she's confirmed to be rose tyler
which she's not
might she be
might she be some kind of alternate
version of rose tyler yes that's not out
of the realm of possibilities that is
not confirmed for people who have been
paying attention to the fact that that
is not confirmed the second most popular
theory is that this rose is donna's
daughter because you'll recall donna got
married at the end of the end of time
part two now the timeline
it's a little squishy if this is donna's
daughter but not
horrendously so yasmine can he is
herself 1819 right about there
so
that is more time than his past it's
been about 12 years and it'll have been
by the time the this airs in 2023 13
years from the last time we saw donna
and she did not appear to be pregnant
at her wedding however
it is worth noting that a
yasmin kinney in the role she plays on
heart stoppers is already playing a 16
year old 16 17. so she's already been
playing slightly young so just because
she is uh you know more 18 19 doesn't
mean that that is what she's going to be
playing and additionally just adding a
couple more years to the actual amount
of time that's passed
i don't think that's going to be that
big a deal because while not incredibly
visibly both catherine tate and david
tennant and bernard crippets have aged
at least a bit and it's
you know they've aged about 12 years but
you know you can stretch that a little
more to say it's been
16 years it's been 17 years
that's feasible in which case if that is
true this would be
rose uh temple noble
and
that to me
makes more sense than this being some
kind of alternate version of rose tyler
which again i'm not going to eliminate
as a possibility and again much as with
exactly how the 10th doctor and donna
slot into this rtd is being very coy and
being very well you'll find out next
year and yep no this is another rose and
i think that's part of why some people
have said oh she's rose tyler because he
said she's another rose like
all that that just as well means that
it's another character named rose
and it's also worth pointing out rtd has
messed with fans before when it comes to
naming in case you forgot there was a
recurring main character in the sarah
jane adventures named
ronnie
and had
zero connection to the classic era
villain
the ronnie
so
he is not above
messing with us he's done it before
and i think he kind of enjoys doing it
at least a little bit does that mean
that this rose has absolutely no
connection to the uh existing characters
that theories are currently tying her to
no doesn't mean that either it just
means that good luck nailing down what's
actually going on ahead
of when rtd wants to tell us while we
may continue to get more leaks about who
is actually appearing and or what
creatures are appearing etc because if
you're shooting in any place that is
publicly accessible
too many people have phones with cameras
on them it's going to get photographed
it's going to be leaked that you can't
stop but the nature of the script and
the story and exactly who these people
are and how the story pans out that you
can keep a lid on and he seems content
to do so i want to bring up a
possibility that i don't think i'd i'd
really considered when i talked last
time last video uh which if you haven't
seen yet there's the thing
i talked about how i'm very nervous if
the 60th anniversary is
uh the first
one to have should igatwa as the new
doctor because sharing space with tenant
when he is kind of the fan favorite
and arguably the most beloved and
arguably with the most beloved companion
pairing on top of that that has the risk
of sucking the oxygen out of the room
here's something that i hadn't really
considered yet that i saw somebody
mentioned i went
okay that's true which is just because
they appear to be filming what is so far
as we know and yes maybe things are
being lied about but
if you're going to go down the path then
you literally call into question every
single thing that has been said so far
and i'm not going to go there i'm going
to assume that the things that have been
said
are accurate and i'm trying to avoid
excessive speculation into the areas
that have been more vague
but
in any case it is possible that even if
they are currently shooting the 60th
anniversary special
that does not necessarily need to be the
next one because
they may have moved up the shooting
for at the very least this section
of the 60th anniversary special
because
david tennant especially is really busy
and this might have been the only
opening in his schedule
which i haven't seen people speculating
about this yet but i expect to so i'll
shoot this out there given the fact that
right now we have set pictures of
tennant
tate
cribbins
and oh also a director rachel talale who
directed a number of episodes from
series eight nine and ten including some
of the best such as heaven sent and uh
world enough in time in the doctor falls
so like if she's directing this that's
awesome but
there hasn't been citing as yet of
shootigatoa on these sets or by a tardis
or anything like that i ha as i said i
haven't seen the speculation yet but i
won't be surprised if some people are
already speculating that he does not
appear in this well actually i'll revise
that i have seen people speculating that
although they aren't citing the lack of
images of him by a tardis or whatever as
reason for it but it is distinctly
possible just based off how busy
david tennant is and i mean also
catherine tate but david tennant more so
this might have been the opening for him
to shoot his portion of what's going on
and it's distinctly possible not only
that shooting gotcha is going to be
filming his parts
separately in a different location or at
a later date but there's enough time
between now and when this is supposed to
air for them to
script and shoot at least another
special
and i'm kind of holding out hope for
that to be the case
i am very excited to see what we're
going to get with this new doctor and i
really don't want to see the oxygen
sucked out of the air by the presence of
the fan favorite doctor
so
that i'm kind of holding on a little
hope for that that the reason that the
60th is being shot now which seems like
pretty well ahead of things uh is
because of scheduling which might open
up possibilities of stuff to happen
between
then then and now and yes i'm still
seeing the ramp and speculation that no
whitaker will regenerate into tenant and
then tenant will later regenerate
like which still makes absolutely no
sense to me it makes zero zero sense and
would be a really terrible idea because
you regenerate uh into
the into tenant whether he be the 10th
doctor again or some new 14th doctor but
then only get like one special of them
before the next person comes in like
that's just a terrible idea you're just
gonna take off all the people who wanted
him to stick around you have to present
it as a special and having like this
weird like they got away with the mayfly
um kind of doctor thing with the war
doctor but that's because we already
knew who came after we were backfilling
somebody in between it's not like we
watched somebody regenerate into john
hurt and then after one special
regenerated to somebody else he was
slotted into existing stuff so it's not
the same thing
i suppose the other thing that's worth
addressing
i have really nothing in particular to
say about it but i think uh for me
especially it'll be a glario mission if
i don't say it which is that
yasmin kinney is a trans woman that does
not mean that she is playing a trans
character we don't know that either way
however she herself is trans and
there is
frankly been an increased visibility of
um trans performers and characters in
doctor who of late but this will by far
be the biggest and most pronounced that
we have seen
we had a trans actor in uh sleep no more
although no real attention was brought
up to that and it was a supporting
character just part of the pool of
people who were gonna die i don't really
like that episode has nothing to do with
the fact that they killed a trans
character i just don't think it's a good
episode so but we have had that uh more
recently on big finish we've had rebecca
root in doctor who's stranded who is a
recurring companion there's the audios
that bbc itself is now producing doctor
who redacted uh which features charlie
craggs as a tran another trans character
um and that one i should get around to
listening to that because that's also
written by juno dawson who um i would
like to find some of her work that i
enjoy i reviewed a doctor who novel she
wrote a little while back i
was not kind to it if you want to see
that review it's there um but i'd like
to enjoy her stuff so i should give that
a shot but i have not listened to that
as yet my point just being that
a trans presence in doctor who overall
has been slowly picking up steam now i'm
seeing also some people claim that this
rose that yasmin kinney is playing is
going to be the new companion presumably
to shootigatwa's doctor that is possible
we
don't know
that yet
with my luck that'll have been confirmed
by the time i get this video freaking
live but no we don't know that yet
again we don't even know if she's
playing a trans character at all
she doesn't necessarily have to be
or very well she could be and it's
simply not ever addressed because
the doctor sure as heck would have no
reason to bring it up
but who knows who knows we don't know
that much
but we knew enough
that i had to crank out
another one of these
russell
be gentle
please
i'd like to get other stuff done
but for right now
whatever your thoughts are on this stuff
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills and allows me to
spend a huge chunk of my day
uh
turning this out because i'm not having
to fit this in between shifts at a day
job so any amount of support you can
give is greatly appreciated even if you
can't like share subscribe help me out
as well don't worry all that much about
it though like i really appreciate it i
really really do but
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings as many dang times as i have to
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters immudelkey the oath the boy tt
for knobby lax the poodle zach paul
idoln tracy scrappet vincent paul
bartolucci angry casper toku bl whovian
adam rdl taylor shane ross shaylee
gourlay and brendan larose you want to
hear me mispronounce your name check out
rewards on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]